Speaker 1: Donald Trump has finally broken his
silence on the FBI raid of his Mar a Lago home,
and he instantly imploded on his very net, now
extraordinarily famous platform. Truth social,
you know, truth social. It's an exciting place.
Speaker 2: Trust Central.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So the big news, of course, over
the last 48 hours that the FBI executed a search
warrant at Donald Trump's home in Florida. They
were in his safe. They were in his office. They
were presumably in his residence. We don't yet
know the full scope of the search warrant or what
they took or what they were seeking. But Donald
Trump breaking his silence on Tuesday with one
post on Truth Social and then spent most of this
morning posting about it. Completely embarrassing
posts starting yesterday with, quote, a horrible
thing that took place yesterday at Mar a Lago.
We are no better than a third world country,
a banana republic. People not being above the
law is not exactly third world stuff. It is
a continuation of Russia, Russia, Russia.
Impeachment Hoax one Impeachment Hoax two the no
collusion Mueller report and more. Well, that's
not true. This has nothing to do with that. This
has to do with Trump at the end of his presidency
taking documents. It has nothing to do with those
other things. And then Trump goes on to say,
To make matters worse, it is all, in my opinion,
a coordinated attack with radical left Democrat,
state and local district attorneys and attorneys
general. There is no evidence whatsoever of that.
And in fact, the report is that Biden did not even
know in advance about this. Then Trump continuing
on truth social quote by. I didn't knew all about
this. Just like he knew about all of Hunter's
deals. It does not appear that that is true. A
report from Politico is that indeed the Biden
administration had no advance notice about the
Mar a Lago search. Could they be lying? Sure,
anyone could be lying at any time. But at this
point, there is no evidence that Biden even knew
ahead of time about this. Trump, continuing
what took place yesterday and long before,
was an unprecedented infringement of the rights of
every American citizen. No, it wasn't. They had a
search warrant. They had a judge sign it. The FBI
director presumably knew about it. The attorney
general presumably knew about it. And everybody
was involved. Presumably dotting T's and crossing
I's. As who was it that said the other day? I
think it was. HANNITY that said something about
dotting T's and crossing I's. Trump Going on scam
after scam year after year. It is all the radical
Democrats really know. It is their lifeblood. They
have no shame and our country is paying a very big
price. Accountability is a good thing, not a
bad thing. Trump continuing his tirade, quote,
The FBI and others from the federal government
would not let anyone, including my lawyers,
be anywhere near the areas that were rummaged
and otherwise looked at during the raid on Mar a
Lago. Everyone was asked to leave the premises.
They wanted to be left alone without witnesses
taking or hopefully not planting, planting there.
Now, this is the new thing, planting evidence.
We'll get to that. Why did they strongly insist
on having nobody watching them, everybody out?
Obama and Clinton were never raided despite
big disputes. What on earth would you have
raided Barack Obama for? I mean, it just,
quite frankly, makes no sense whatsoever.
So Donald Trump exploding troth essential and
making a dozen or more unfounded assertions.
This thing about nobody was allowed there.
Look at the commentary from former FBI agents
about what is and is not allowed during the
execution of such search warrants. And you
will find that at this time there's
no evidence anything wrong was done.